[Music]
straight ahead
online crime daily and they are replete
with racist
and bigot remarks prosecutors accused
three defendants of targeting a black
man
in georgia why text messages and
facebook posts
might be admitted into evidence in the
ahmad arbory case
plus were officers justified in the
briana taylor shooting
an inside look into the grand jury
proceedings
and exclusive analysis from our experts
and a defendant proves her attorney
botched her case
so why does the prosecution get to read
her defense attorney's private files
law and crime daily covers court cases
from coast to coast
and welcome to long crime daily i'm erin
keller along with brian buckmeyer and
terry austin and we're glad you're with
us
let's start in texas where a police
officer is facing murder charges terry
austin has
this developing story terry erin the
officer is facing murder charges for
shooting and killing an unarmed man
outside of a gas station
the texas rangers say wolf city police
officer
sean lucas responded to a disturbance
call
and encountered 31 year old jonathan
price
the officer reportedly attempted to
detain price
and price was walking away when lucas
tased him
and shot him a spokesperson for the
texas rangers said
lucas's actions were quote not
objectionably
reasonable an attorney for price's
family says
price was a hometown hero and a stand-up
guy
and was only trying to help a woman out
of a domestic violence situation
lucas is out of jail on a one million
dollar bond
thanks terry let's head to georgia now
where long crime daily's brian buckmeyer
has the latest developments in the ahmad
arbury case brian
georgia prosecutors say they have proof
of a motive in the deadly shooting of a
man
out jogging earlier this year
three defendants are charged with
killing 25 year old ahmad arbury
prosecutors say gregory mcmichael
started chasing aubry as he left a
construction site
son travis mcmichael is accused of
firing the shots
william rhodey brian is charged with
blocking arbury with his vehicle
and joining the chase all three are
claiming self-defense
but in a court motion just filed the
state says
data collected through a search of their
electronic devices
reveals a racial motive among the
messages found
on trapsman michael's facebook
authorities say they have
what they describe as a racial highway
video post
and a racial johnny rebel post from
gregory mcmichael
an identity dixie post and a racial
johnny rebel post
and apparently they found racist text
messages
on william bryan's phone prosecutors
reveal the messages
at a bond hearing over the summer
we have a number of text communications
that were extracted from this
defendant's phone
and they are replete with racist and
video remarks
and communications which goes directly
to the risk of flight and concern
that this defendant might pose a risk
once the department of justice has time
to
just digest this repeatedly this
defendant uses the n-word
a term that i had to look up bootlet
talks about monkey parades
working like an end today there was just
a ton of built
in this defendant's text regarding that
and one of the investigators on this
case testified during a pre-trial
hearing that while at the crime scene
brian told
him that he overheard one of the other
defendants
used the n-word saying that it might be
a little uncomfortable to talk about the
words because it involves a curse word
and something else i need to ask you
about that quote can you please
articulate for the court
what mr brian said he heard travis
mcmichael say
prior to police arriving after the fatal
shooting
yes um mr brian said that
after the shooting took place before
police arrival
while mr aubry was on the ground
that he heard travis michael make the
statement
i spoke recently with the director of
the georgia bureau of investigation
about the ahmad arbury case he said the
arrest came
quickly once the state stepped in
once the georgia bureau of investigation
became involved in that case within a
36-38 hour time frame we had warrants
issued for the arrest of two individuals
we conducted the remainder of our
investigation before we
made the decision that probable cause
existed to arrest the third defendant we
did that
at this point it's dependent on the
court system working
i've been involved in that system my
entire life in some
some aspect of or another i've won i've
been a witness
i've been a prosecutor i've been a
defense attorney i've been a judge
and i'm confident that the system will
work in this case does it work fast
enough no
never never does particularly if you
have a loved one in it or you have some
personal involvement in it but i am
absolutely categorically 100 percent
confident
that it's going to work in this case and
that in the end justice will prevail
brian and terry here now with tiffany
simmons an attorney from atlanta georgia
so tiffany prosecutors are saying they
want to get these so-called racial text
messages and statements
into the cases for two reasons one of
those reasons is under rule
404 the rules of evidence as evidence
they're saying as a
pattern of conduct so is your sense that
this is strong enough evidence to meet
the conduct requirements or is it
character evidence because character
evidence is inadmissible generally
well according to the federal rules of
evidence you are correct
character evidence is inadmissible
however when you're using the evidence
to show
um to prove motive to prove opportunity
to prove intent preparation planning and
knowledge
that is permissible in court so for the
purposes of this case
those emails and text messages if they
can show
opportunity intent motive um
planning knowledge it is admissible in
court
so the key is the if you use there
tiffany you have to have a pretty strong
chain or nexus to prove that this
evidence is directly related
to what's alleged well
you do however um
i believe that if they just show that
again that
this goes towards the motive um
opportunity
then it should be able to be in
admissible and that's really up to the
judge
certainly brian another reason
prosecutors want these messages into the
case is just as intrinsic evidence
basically simply saying
this is evidence in a document we should
be able to present it it's the
defendant's own words
exactly and the fact that you had as we
saw earlier that officer come up and
saying these are words
that the defendant used travis mcmichael
used after shooting and killing a mod
arbory
i mean what what tiffany's talking about
the acronym we usually use is mimic
it's motive intense mistake or lack
thereof identity and common scheme of
plan
the first three being mode of intent or
lack of mistake are pretty strong
on the prosecutor's side when it comes
to this evidence coming in so terry
if this evidence gets in it's damaging
for these defendants does it get in in
your opinion
i think it could get in erin and i agree
with brian and tiffany
it definitely shows some motive here the
reason why they went after a modern
artery
and you know i think what the judge
overall has to weigh is whether it's
more
probative than it is prejudicial et
cetera and i think
it could get in we have other rules of
evidence that we need to sort these
through too not just that 404
character versus conduct we've got to
have basic relevance standards as well
great discussion on that case and still
ahead here on law and crime daily
a supreme court justice with harsh words
about whether prosecutors
are playing fairly in a case that she
reviewed but first
a closer look at the grand jury's
decision to charge one officer but not
any others in the police shooting
of briana taylor law on crime daily
returns in just a moment
[Music]
let's head now to louisville kentucky
and the deadly no knock warrant in the
briana taylor case kentucky's attorney
general has released 15 hours worth of
recordings from those grand jury
proceedings
and law and crime daily's brian
buckmeyer has been combing through them
over the weekend and including into
today brian
yeah so it's been a lot when you when
you look at the mall at the end of the
day what's really difficult
you don't get the charges that the grand
jury actually had at the end of the day
we don't know
what if at all the prosecutors said is
self-defense
is manslaughter is homicide we don't
even know if homicide or manslaughter
were
told to the the grand jury and so the
end of the day
all the facts and information that i
have the ability to comb through
is really for nothing we don't get that
that last bit at the end
the prosecutors presented evidence over
two and a half
days and they laid out a timeline of
events
starting from when the officers arrived
at taylor's house on march the 13th
investigators say the officers executing
the warrant were not wearing body
cameras
but jurors were able to watch his body
cam videos from back up
responding to the house after the
shooting they also listened to the 911
calls
from taylor's neighbors and from her
boyfriend kenny walker
members of the jury questioned why there
was a five minute
time lapse between 9-1-1 calls
the officers got on scene about 0-0-35
march 13th they began to expect the
warrant
zero zero forty these are pockets but
nobody's gonna have to watch the zero
zero forty
the first now i wanna call him
at 12 43 53 seconds
next call that we have here is 12 44 08
next we have 12 45 and we don't have any
seconds
zero zero 45 and then walker calls
kenneth walker calls from the apartment
four
at 12 50 and 13 seconds now i can't
begin to speculate what he was doing and
why he waited but that is another time
for obviously
[Music]
attorney ben crump represents brianna
taylor's family he said taylor's
boyfriend had every right to fire his
gun in self-defense
on who he thought was an intruder but
who turned out to be
the police brianna didn't have a good
brianna didn't pose a threat to anybody
she was literally in her underwear and
by officer
mattingly's own account he said in this
statement that
he knew that brianna was unarmed
so if you knew that then why would you
be shooting at an
unarmed black woman in her own apartment
and i have to say this eddie walker
brianna's boyfriend
who is a law-abiding citizen never
committed a crime in his life never been
arrested
in his life a registered gun owner
doesn't he have a right to the second
amendment
didn't kenny walker have the right to
self-defense
so shouldn't all of these facts be
presented to the grand jury
so they can deliberate as to if the
police violated policies and procedures
and it was their actions that was the
proximate cause that caused brianna
taylor
to be killed and at least the
recommendation of second-degree
manslaughter should go forward
so terry we really get into a collision
of law here because if the police are
fired upon they have a legal right to
defend themselves
as to the person who's firing the person
who believes
he's being invaded has a legal right to
defend
his castle and we have brianna taylor
who by all accounts is an innocent third
party victim here
well that's exactly right aaron and i
agree with crump here you know
mattingly did say that he saw she did
not have a gun
so why did he shoot in her direction and
the fact that
so many bullets were shot obviously
hankinson
shot indiscriminately in a neighboring
apartment
but the fact that we have someone who
died cosgrove and mattingly in fact all
three of them
should have at least manslaughter
charges against them for
a recklessly you know killing someone
who was
happening to stand next to her boyfriend
brian
can the officers in any way be excused
here because their
reviewed statements that the grand jury
reviewed basically suggest oh it was
chaos
we had flashes of light we just started
firing
is that not excusable it's excusable
from
like jury nullification or saying hey
officers have a hard job which they do
and i understand
but from a legal standpoint the only two
questions you have to ask yourself
is one was this manslaughter did he
intend to cause injury to one person
and in fact kill a third party and two
did he respond to someone's use of force
appropriately
and here as it applies to brianna taylor
he didn't because brianna taylor didn't
apply any force to him
tiffany your thoughts on this quickly
should there have been additional
charges filed against these officers
yes there should have been additional
charges um 11 of the 12 witnesses said
that they did not hear the police
officers announce
that they were at the door um at best
this was a botched uh raid and they
should be charged accordingly
appreciate the insight tiffany from
georgia very good to have you on law and
crime daily the rest of us will be back
in a moment because still ahead tonight
a
lurking defendant and an out of control
wildfire
some footage you don't want to miss is
right after this
cameras capture many crazy moments in
courtrooms where they're allowed
court camp by law and crime productions
airs on the a e network here's our
founder dan abrams
first we head to superior court in
orange county california
for a not so typical arraignment hearing
all right let's go forward then on the
case of forrest gordon clark
that's 51 year old forrest gordon clark
in the orange jumpsuit behind the screen
birthday 29th is that your birthday mr
clark
rather than answering the judge clark
lurks in the background
seemingly more preoccupied with the
court's cameras
so how exactly did he end up here
clark's accused of starting the
devastating holy fire in cleveland
national forest
in orange and riverside counties the
fire forced over 20 thousand people in
neighboring communities to evacuate
and took over a month to contain for his
alleged actions clark's facing a
litany of charges including aggravated
arson
arson of inhabited property and arson of
a forest
clark lived in one of the 14 cabins
located in the area of the fire
and his is the only one still standing
in addition clark reportedly had
conflicts with his neighbors for years
and
even sent a text warning of volunteer
fire chief the quote
the place will burn birthday
29th is that your birthday mr clark
29 making matters even more bizarre
today's hearing was scheduled a day
earlier but clark refused to leave his
cell to attend
all right he's declining pardon yay yay
okay thank you sir perhaps for seeing
the
disruptive behavior his attorney nicole
harness
even requested he not be present that
was denied by a court commissioner
and now the judge is struggling to lay
out the formal
charges with clark present uh mr clark
is charged in several counts involving
arson aggravated arson that's a lot
criminal uh threats these are just
allegations sir and resisting correct
miss pardess you wish to continue the
arraignment
yes correct yay
okay all right then your order back on
august 17th that'll be for further
arraignment thank you uh you're welcome
sir we'll see you then bail has been
sent at one million dollars
and you're honored may i pay for that
and you're immediately can we please
have a bill can i post
bail also set on the 17th yeah no i
can't handle a million right now
easily we don't need just everyone quiet
eventually clark pleads not guilty to
the charges
and later two counts of resisting are
dropped
clark remains in custody as he awaits a
trial if convicted he could face
life in prison correct yay
okay and when we come back supreme court
justice sonia sotomayor on a case where
a jury convicted a defendant not once
but twice
and what the justice thinks was unfair
about the verdicts
justice sonia sotomayor raising
questions in a supreme court document
about the ethics of prosecutors in cases
where defendants complain about their
lawyers here are just some of the twists
and turns
at trial defendant reminder cower was
convicted of first-degree murder in
maryland
but she argued on appeal that her
defense attorney provided ineffective
assistance
in order to convince a court that her
attorney performed poorly
the maryland judicial system forced
coward to hand defense documents
over to the very same prosecutors who
tried her a second time
and who won a second conviction against
her cower appealed again
saying it was unfair under the sixth
amendment for prosecutors to see her
first
defense attorney's files the appeals
court ruled against her saying
she failed to demonstrate a realistic
possibility
that she was harmed in the second trial
by the prosecutor's access to her
privileged information
or that the prosecutors used such
information to their advantage
the u.s supreme court refused to take up
the matter and justice sonia sotomayor
agreed that the case
should end but she wrote separately
saying
the prosecution could have been aided
even subconsciously
by reviewing the defense files and
sotomayor notes
the defendant herself refused to testify
at her second trial
because of what the prosecution knew
from those files
prosecutors wield an immense amount of
power and they do so in the name of the
state itself sotomayor wrote
that unique privilege comes with the
exceptional responsibility to ensure
that the criminal justice system
indeed serves the ends of justice
prosecutors fall short of this task
and therefore do a grave disservice to
the people in whose name they litigate
when they permit themselves to enjoy
unfair trial advantages
at defendant's expense here the
prosecutors
should have recused themselves from
participating in cower's
second trial as a matter of professional
conscience
their failure to do so casts a troubling
and unnecessary shadow over cower's
conviction and sentence to life
imprisonment
okay brian there's a lot of moving parts
in this justice sotomayor is basically
saying the prosecutors should have
recused themselves from the case because
they saw the files the second trial was
predicated on a jailhouse statement
from the defendant the wife basically
said that
her husband drugged her and that she
really wasn't involved in the crime with
him that was the two of them together
there
in the gun store surveillance video we
saw so there's a lot of odd layers to
this but the big question is
why is the prosecutor getting the files
to make the decision not the judge
this makes no sense on so many levels
aaron when it comes to ineffective
assists of counsel
it's the defense attorney usually the
new one arguing that the last one did
something improper to the court
it's a two-part test under strickland
one for performance one for prejudice
and nowhere in that in that argument is
the prosecutor even involved so why
they're getting the file makes no sense
furthermore when they get that file they
should be recused because even as
defense attorneys we can't represent
two people from the same case because
that would be a conflict and that would
make us ineffective in representing our
own clients so prosecutors would fall
into the same category yeah i mean once
you get the file arguably you become a
witness in the proceeding as well and
that's another way you could look at
this too and that causes a problem so
so terry justice sotomayor's statement
doesn't carry the weight of law it's
basically in
it's an opinion on a denial to take a
case
but it does give a bit of a road map for
future cases she's saying maybe the next
case
could cause a big problem with this too
well yeah
i agree i mean she was you know
ultimately agreed on the end
end result here but she's trying to make
a statement i think to everybody that
prosecutions
shouldn't work we gotta wrap up we'll
see you next time
[Music]
you